and a good evening to you thank you for
joining us at six i'm bryan loftis and
i'm denise valdez 46 year old jose
rangel will spend two years behind bars
for hiding evidence and also being an
accessory to the murder of 22 year old
leslie palacio joe moeller was in the
courtroom during the sentencing he tells
us what the palacio family plans to do
next i felt like my life has fallen
apart emotions were running high as
statements were read to the man who
played a role in leslie palacio's death
would leslie pass
i was in total shock and i didn't want
to believe that the person i needed the
most was gone jose rennell pleaded
guilty to being an accessory to murder
and hiding evidence friday he was
sentenced to two years in the clark
county detention center the maximum
sentence under current law we do
feel like the system did
fail us in a way although we do know
like they can't do anything like than
given like more than two years it's
still not really justice for us leslie
went missing nearly a year ago family
and friends say the fight is not over we
are today announcing that we are going
to be
talking to legislators to introduce the
leslie palacio law in the state of
nevada
to strengthen the law investigators
believe jose rendell helped hide the
murder for his son eric who is still at
large leslie's mother says they want
justice and they will not stop looking
for him she's asking eric to turn
himself in
and she's also announcing right now that
the family is gonna offer a ten thousand
dollar reward to anyone who has any
information on eric run health so he
could be uh so he could turn himself in
or they can find him so he could be held
accountable
after rennell asked for forgiveness in
court the palacio family says they can't
forgive for what has been done you don't
know the pain that you caused me and my
family your sorry was never sincere joe
mohler 8 news now
ann rangel was sentenced to two years
but 205 days of that sentence have
already been served